Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Schön zu sehen.
Am Anfang möchte ich mich kurz vorstellen.
Mein Name ist Temar Göksu und ich bin Assistent-Assistent in dieser Station.
Frau Doktor, ich bin mir etwas schwerhörig.
Ich bin schon über 80, deswegen müssen Sie mal etwas lauter sprechen.
Ich habe Ihren Namen nicht ganz verstanden.
Können Sie Ihren Namen nochmal sagen?
Mein Name ist Temar Göksu und ich bin Assistent-Ärzte in dieser Station tätig.
Ich möchte gerne mit Ihnen aufnahmegespräch führen.
Gut, Frau Doktor Göksu.
Ja, ich bin einverzandt, Frau Doktor Göksu.
Okay, gut.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder nicht verstehen,
dann bitte Sie mir Bescheid geben.
Und dann machen wir eine kurze Pause und dann ansonsten weitermachen, okay?
Klar, Frau Doktor.
Haben Sie ein bisschen Nachsicht mit mir?
Wie gesagt, ich bin alt und höre nicht so gut.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe, okay.
Und zuerst möchte ich mit Ihnen unsere, Ihre Personaldaten sprechen.
Und dann sofort möchte ich mit Ihnen Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde sprechen.
Okay, einverstanden.
So, wie ist Ihre Name?
Name ist Berthold Brecht.
Wollen Sie auch meinen Personalausweis sehen oder reicht das, wenn ich so sage?
Nein, ich möchte sagen, können Sie Vorname und Nachname buchstabieren, langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, also Vorname ist Berthold.
Schreibt sich BERTHOLDE Berthold.
Nachname ist Brecht.
Okay, gut.
So, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt dies Jahr 80 geworden, habe einen runden Geburtstag gefeiert.
Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Danke schön, Frau Doktor.
Und wann würden Sie geboren?
5. Mai 1943.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich war mal früher 1 Meter 80, aber wie groß ich jetzt bin, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ich bin bestimmt geschrumpft.
Okay, so wie wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 72 Kilogramm.
Okay.
So, was würden Sie uns?
Ja, Frau Doktor, es sind mehrere Sachen, wo fange ich am besten an.
Und zwar bin ich auch zum Hausarzt gegangen heute und der, ich sag es soll ja dann auch ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Ich fühle mich nicht mehr so leistungsfähig wie früher.
Also ich bin körperlich sehr gut.
Ich bin sehr gut.
Ich fühle mich nicht mehr so leistungsfähig wie früher.
Also ich bin körperlich nicht mehr so fit.
Das geht seit, ich muss sagen, einige Monaten.
Ich habe es auch immer zurückgefügt.
Ich hatte in den letzten Monaten auch viele Infektionen gehabt.
Also ich hatte drei, vier Mal Grippe gehabt.
Und da bin ich jetzt nie so richtig fit geworden.
Ich habe immer gesagt, es wird noch besser, aber das bleibt so.
Was ich auch noch habe, es sind, ja, Hausarzt sagt, es sind Luftknoten.
Das sind Knoten am Hals, die ich hier gespürt habe, auf beiden Seiten.
Und was habe ich noch dem Hausarzt erzählt?
Also ich habe ein bisschen Yukreis.
Das hatte ich früher auch nicht.
Und ich krieg gleich da blau Flecken.
Das habe ich ihm noch gesagt.
Ich habe mich gestoßen, habe ich gleich so blau Flecken.
Das war früher auch nicht so gewesen.
Und das waren so die wichtigsten Sachen.
Und der Hausarzt hat letzte Woche bei mir Blut abgenommen.
Und dann sagt er, ja, ich misse ins Kackenhaus,
weil an den Blutzellen stimmt nicht.
Es stimmt etwas nicht.
Also ich hätte zu wenig rotes Blut, grote Blutkörper,
also Blutarmut und noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Das sollte abgeklärt werden, an der Gesamt.
Okay, so.
Was ich auch noch vergessen habe,
war, und da hatte ich auch eine Göttelrose gehabt.
Auf der rechten Seite.
Auf der rechten Seite, wie bitte?
Hatte ich eine Göttelrose.
Okay.
Seit einigen Monaten, sagen Sie,
so zwei Monate, drei Monate, oder?
Sie meint jetzt diese schwäche, körperliche Schwäche?
Ja, körperliche Schwäche und drei
und viermal Infektionen gehabt.
Also ich kann es nicht ganz genau sagen, Frau Doktor,
weil ich hatte halt, also ich muss sagen, seit dem Winter,
da dies Jahr, seit dem Winter, habe ich viele Infektionen gehabt.
Also so viel wie noch nie.
Und seitdem habe ich mich auch nie richtig erholt.
Es war mal immer besser, aber nicht ganz gut.
Also ich kann sagen,
seit ein halben Jahr bin ich körperlich nicht mehr so viel früher.
Okay.
Sie haben Schwäche
und haben Lymphknoten, Schwollen, ja?
Ja, da hat er gesagt, das wären Lymphknoten am Hals, ja.
Und Yukrides haben Sie?
Das habe ich Ihnen gesagt, ja, den Haushalt.
Das habe ich auch seit einigen Wochen, habe ich das jetzt.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt beim Stuhlgang Bullut?
Bullut habe ich nicht gemerkt,
aber der Stuhlgang ist ein bisschen anders als früher.
Also früher hatte ich, also regelmäßig Stuhlgang,
so jeden Tag eigentlich.
Jetzt habe ich manchmal alle zwei, drei Tage keinen Stuhlgang.
Also es hat sich ein bisschen geändert vom Stuhlgang her.
Das ist auch nicht mehr so früher.
Das war Durchfall oder Stopfung?
Also eher jetzt, dass ich da Verstopfung hatte.
Das hat nicht jeden Tag,
sondern hat alle zwei, drei Tage erst Stuhlgang bekommen,
aber es früher nicht der Fall war.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Waslassen?
Also das übliche, also ich habe seit vielen Jahren,
da habe ich, muss ich nachts ein, zwei Mal raus,
aber da war ich auch beim Uralogen gesagt,
die Depositor ist vergrößert.
Und hat sich aber seit den letzten Jahren nicht geändert.
Also ich muss immer ein, zwei Mal nachts aufdehnen zum Wasser lassen.
Okay.
Habt ihr Fieber?
Fieber habe ich jetzt aktuell nicht.
Also als ich die Infektion hatte,
hatte ich auch mal Fieber gehabt, aber jetzt nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Vielleicht ein bisschen weniger als sonst,
aber ich habe nicht abgenommen.
Also ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Aber es ist weniger als früher, muss ich sagen.
Hab ich glaube, sich aufgeteht?
Haben Sie Öbel?
Ist Ihnen Öbel oder schon einmal Erbrochen?
Nein.
Öbel, oder Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Sie sagte nicht abgenommen, ja?
Nein, also, Gewicht ist ungewöhnlich.
Auch nicht, nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, also ich habe nie gut geschlafen,
aber es ist so wie immer.
Also ich habe schon seit vielen Jahren,
habe ich immer Durchschaustörungen,
vielleicht auch, weil ich nachts aufstehen muss,
das ist seit 20 Jahren so unverändert.
Ich würde sagen normal.
Okay.
In Ordnung.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen Ihre Vorerkrankungen sprechen.
So haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen,
wie zum Beispiel Blutdruck, Druckzuckerkrankheit,
erhöhte Blutdruck.
Blutdruck habe ich, ja.
Ich habe auch Medikamente, die ich einnehmen,
wegen Bluthochdruck.
Ich hatte mal vor, na ungefähr,
mal 10 Jahren,
wenn ich mal einen kleinen Schlaganfall gehabt habe,
aber das hat sich jetzt alles wieder gebessert.
Und ich hatte mal eine Operation von der Hüfte,
da bin ich mal gestürzt,
habe mir die Hüfte gebrochen,
da habe ich eine Brothese.
Entschuldigung.
Bitte langsam sprechen
und ich muss diese Informationen dokumentieren.
Okay.
Sie hat Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Oh, weiß ich nicht, schon viele Jahre.
20 Jahre bestimmt schon.
20, okay.
Nehmen Sie eine Medikamente gegen Bluthochdruck ein?
Richtig, ja.
Wie ist diese Name?
Ich packe mein Zettel mal aus.
Kann der Satan?
Wie viel Milligramm das ist?
16 Milligramm steht drauf.
Und so, vor 10 Jahren
haben Sie Schlaganfall gehabt, ja.
Richtig, ja.
Haben Sie keine Bewegung erschwähnt,
oder?
Ne, hat sich wieder alles gebessert, ja.
Okay.
Gegen Schlaganfall nehmen Sie Medikamente ein?
Ja, da habe ich Aspirin, nämlich ein.
Und dann habe ich noch so einen
Kolesterolinsänger bekommen damals.
Dann muss ich auch nehmen,
jeden Abend.
Wissen Sie diese Name?
Ja, Arturvastatin, 20 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie am Abend oder?
Am Abend, ja.
Einmal am Tag, ja?
Ja, einmal abends, ja.
Kann der Satan?
Morgenabend?
Morgenabend nehme ich dann ein, ja.
ASS?
Haben Sie am Morgen oder?
Nehmen Sie morgens ein, ja.
Wie viel Milligramm?
100 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Sonst habe ich nichts Festes.
Okay, andere Blutverdünne haben Sie?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein.
So, und dann sagt sie,
Sie sagten, Hüftgelenkoperationen, ja.
Nach Sturz, ja.
Wann war das?
8 Jahre vielleicht, ja.
Okay.
Das Operationen ist komplikationlos?
Ja, komplikationslos, ja.
Total, total genenkt?
Totalprothesie, ja.
Haben Sie andere
Oppositionen gehabt?
Linda, als Jugendlicher.
Sonst keine.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe früher geraucht, aber schon lange aufgehört.
Seit 35 Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr.
Da war ich ungefähr so 55 oder so.
Seit 30 Jahren?
Raue ich nicht mehr, ja.
Okay.
Damals rauchen Sie, wie viel?
Also es war mal ein Päckchen, dann war es mal, wie ich es aufgehört habe,
dann wieder angefangen, also sagen wir mal,
ich habe vielleicht so 30 Jahre geraucht ungefähr.
Seit wann damals haben Sie geraucht?
Mit 20 angefangen und dann ist wieder durch den Aufgehörter bis 50.
Also wie gesagt ungefähr,
wenn man es sammere, dann vielleicht 30 Jahre.
30 Jahre.
2 Packung am Tag, ja?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Eine Packung, maximal, manchmal weniger.
Aber mit Film, nicht 2 Packungen.
Entschuldigung.
Sie denken, Alkohol?
Selten, nur wenn ich in der Gesellschaft bin.
Es gibt auch mal Monate, wo ich gar keinen Alkohol trink,
also selten, würde ich sagen.
Einmal am Monat, ja?
Ja, wenn es sich ergibt, wenn ein Anlass da ist, ja.
Kontaktieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich es nicht zu tun,
warum fragen Sie?
Entschuldigung, bitte nehmen Sie persönlich,
das ist eine regelmäßige Frage.
Muss ich alle, jedem Patient fragen muss.
Auch 80jährige Patienten fragen Sie nach Drogen.
Gibt es so viele 80-jährige, die Drogen nehmen oder warum?
Ja, aber Entschuldigung, ich muss fragen.
Man weiß nicht, Sie haben recht, man kann nicht wissen.
Der Drogen nimmt heute Tage, stimmt.
Okay.
Und waren Sie im letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war schon pro,
sehr, sehr lange nicht im Ausland, ich war immer in Deutschland.
Okay, und haben Sie regelmäßig geimpft?
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe nur jetzt diese Corona-Impfung gehabt,
drei Mal, aber ansonsten bei anderen Impfungen,
muss ich sagen, weiß ich nicht genau.
Grippe gegen Grippe?
Grippe habe ich nicht gemacht, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Also da habe ich mir gedrückt vor der Grippe-Impfung.
Hat der Haushaltsverband immer wieder angeboten,
aber ich habe es eigentlich nie gemacht.
Okay.
Aber ab jetzt mache ich, war Lockta.
Wie bitte?
Ab jetzt mache ich, weil ich so viel Infektion hatte,
mache ich ab jetzt, im nächsten Winter mache ich Grippe-Impfung.
Da habe ich mir vorgenommen.
Das ist in Ordnung, was meinen Sie?
Soll ich das machen?
Ich glaube, Sie haben viele chronische Erkrankungen,
Schlaganfall, ich habe sie Bluthoch zurück,
und Alter haben sie Risiken über Infektionen.
So, ich schlage diese Grippe-Impfung geimpft,
aber ja, sie sind Chef und schlage aber, sie entscheiden.
Sie würden empfehlen, oder?
Ja.
Aber nicht jetzt im Sommer oder jetzt auch im Sommer schon,
oder soll ich das erst im Herbst, im Winter machen lassen?
Im Herbst, besser, ja.
Okay, gut.
Ich werde dich machen, Herr Doktor, danke für den Arztschlag.
Okay, gut, schön.
So, haben Sie, wie ist Ihre Familienstand?
Ich bin verwidert.
Verwidert, okay.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne allein in meiner Wohnung.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder, sie sind schon erwachsen,
und alle wohnen weit weg.
Wir sehen uns immer zu Weihnachten.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Also, soweit ich weiß, ja,
keine schweren Krankheiten zumindest mal.
Also, okay.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich hatte zwei Geschwester, sie sind alle verstorben.
Es tut mir leid.
Wissen Sie, woran haben diese Geschwester gestorben?
Also, meine Schwester hatte Krebs, Wusskrebs,
und dann habe ich noch einen älteren Bruder,
der hat einen Schlaganfall gehabt,
und dann war er pflegefallen, ist dann gestorben.
Und haben Sie gegen etwas Allergische oder Unverzweglichkeit?
Ist mir nicht bekannt, Herr Doktor.
Nein, nein, nein.
Jetzt habe ich alle Fragen,
muss ich fragen,
und haben Sie andere Begleitende,
oder möchten Sie etwas fragen?
Also, ich wollte noch erwähnen,
dass ich mich bei der Untersuchung habe,
wenn ich drücke auf der linken Seite im Bauch,
habe ich ein bisschen Schmerzen,
nicht aber Druck gefühlt,
wenn ich da auftaste, dann muss es vielleicht ein bisschen weh.
Das hat bei der Untersuchung festgestellt, der Hausarzt.
Und das ist sonst,
habe ich jetzt keine anderen Sachen, die mir einführen.
Was meinen Sie,
muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben,
und dann muss ich das Abkampulanz abklären?
Das Hausarzt meint, ich soll Sie fragen,
wo es jetzt nicht genau,
ob ich da bleiben muss,
und ich soll im Krankenhaus nachfragen.
Okay.
Jetzt machen wir schon
nur an einem Nestgespräch.
Was ist so frisch?
Sagen wir Diagnose
oder wollen wir
im Ambulanten bleiben
oder nicht gehen Sie Hause oder nicht?
Wir wollen mit Ihnen
körperliche Untersuchung machen
und dann ich spiele hier mit meinem Chef,
über Ihre Wische werden.
Und dann entscheiden wir
Ambulanten,
oder in Haus gehen,
oder was.
Und das ist so frisch.
Okay, dann machen Sie jetzt Untersuchung
und dann besprechen Sie mit dem Chef,
ob ich dann da bleiben muss
und dann machen wir das auch.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich denke, viele Fragen
deswegen
fragen unsere Kollegen.
Noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe Fragen.
Hallo Herr Brett,
haben Sie
Stärfrost oder Stärfrost?
Nachtschweiß,
haben Sie erste Frage?
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht, Nachtschweiß auch nicht.
Okay.
Sie haben
am heißen Knoten gesagt.
Haben Sie auf anderen Konferten
Knoten?
Also ich habe die Knoten gar nicht gemerkt, der Haushalt hat das
bei Untersuchung festgestellt, also ich habe das gar nicht so richtig gemerkt.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie auch volle Gefühle?
Völle Gefühle?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, nein.
Andere Frage,
Sie haben Blauplecken.
Ja.
Blauplecken, Alekvater,
Alekvater, oder
eine Porkartäle?
Man kann verschiedene Stellen, also mal beinahe mal Arm, aber auch nicht überall, also es
hält sich in Grenzen.
Okay, danke schön.
Danke auch.
Noch andere Kollegen?
Gut.
Sie haben sich die Gewicht merklich verändert.
Hat sie gefragt, das war aber ohne große Änderung, keine Änderung
vom Gewicht.
Sie haben gesagt, Fieber.
Aktuell nicht, aber bei den Infektionen,
ich hatte, habe ich Fieber gehabt.
Wie viele Monaten und wie lange dauert Ihre Fieber?
Wie oft?
Schwierig, weil ich hatte mehrere Infektions-Episoden gehabt
und ich hatte immer wieder mal ein, zwei Tage Fieber, vielleicht.
Aber nicht bei jeder Infektion, muss man auch dazu sagen, also sehr
inkonstant.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel Aktuell konsumieren,
dann führt Ihre
heiß ein bisschen Schmerzen.
Hat er nicht gemerkt, nein.
Schäd ist noch hier Gelbshut,
hat er nicht gehabt, weiß er nicht.
Haben Sie ungewöld Bauchschmerzen
oder Bruchschmerzen?
Ja, nur wenn man diese linke Oberbauch hat,
hat er beschwerd, wenn man so ein bisschen drückt, Hausarzt bei der Untersuchung,
hat er festgestellt, dass er da Druckschmerzen hat
im linken Oberbau.
Sonst keine anderen Schmerzen.
Bekunden Sie Luft schwer?
Luft ist normal,
hat nicht gemerkt.
Wir haben gesagt, ich habe Hausarzt eine Labor,
eine Brüche für.
Haben Sie ihre Laborergebnisse dabei?
Ja, eine Mie hat er von 9,5.
Trombozytten sind bei 90.000.
Neukozytten bei 20.000.
Danke.
Ich denke, jetzt alle Fragen gestärkt.
Können wir mal gemacht werden?
Okay.
Guten Tag Herr Doktor.
Ich würde gerne...
Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag Herr Doktor.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen über meine Patientin
gesprochen und vorstellen.
Ihr seid für mich.
Ja bitte, können wir gerne machen.
Herr Bertolt Brecht.
Er ist 80-jähriger Patient.
Er ist am 15. Mai.
Er ist 80 Jahre alt.
Ich brauche die Geburtsdaten von Patienten nicht.
Wir haben wenig Zeit.
Wir versuchen zu kompakt vorzustellen.
Heute hat er
in Hausarzt
gegegangen.
Er hat seit halben Jahr
Schwäche und die in diesem Zeit drei oder vier Mal Infektionen gehabt und hausart gesagt,
er hat große Lymphknoten und beide Seite heisst im All, beide Seite.
Haben Sie nach untersucht, haben Sie die Lymphknoten auch getastet?
Sie haben nach untersucht, ja.
Wie sind die, können Sie die beschreiben, die Lymphknoten?
Erzählen Sie irgendwas.
Das Lymphknoten ist...
Welche Regionen ungefähr?
Welche?
Welche Regionen?
Submandibulär, Submental, superklavikulär.
Superklavikulär hat er beide Seite.
Und Zervikalen auch, haben Sie getastet? Zervikal.
Ja, und Zervikal.
Wie groß sind die Lymphknoten ungefähr?
Ungefähr zwei Zentimeter.
Warst immer ganz gut, dass man das mit bestimmten Angaben,
zwei Zentimeter ist schwer vorstellbar, man sagt immer, kirsch groß,
Walnuss groß, Tennisball groß, wie groß würden Sie beschreiben?
Wie linden?
Linden, was sind linden?
Ich würde sagen, Merchamika-Bahn.
Zwei Zentimeter ist ein bisschen groß für Linsen.
Linsen, ja.
Zwei Zentimeter ist ungefähr, ich würde sagen,
fast Walnuss groß, zwei Zentimeter, kleine Walnuss.
Oder hat die Lymphknoten Schmelzos?
Das kommt noch, sie sind zu schnell, ich wollte erst mal die Größe.
Verschiedene Aspekte müssen wir besprechen.
Also, ersten Größe, am besten wenn Sie mit so,
zwei Zentimeter ist korrekt, aber Sie können schreiben,
z.B. kirsch groß oder linsen groß,
oder Tennisball groß oder Ticht-Tennisball groß,
das ist immer ganz zum visuellen Vorstellung.
Oder die Lymphknoten ist verschiebbar,
deswegen kann ich nicht messen.
Ich kann nicht gemessen.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Wenn Lymphknoten, wenn man Tasten kann,
verschieblich sind, kann man trotzdem messen, die Größe, kann man angeben.
Wenn er sein, hier, und Sie können verschieben,
dann können Sie die Größe angeben, sagen Sie.
Walnuss groß, Lymphknoten verbacken oder gut verschieblich?
Verschieblich, okay.
Gut verschieblich, also gut verschieblich sind Sie.
Und dann noch eine Angabe, müssen Sie machen bei der Körperknoten,
ob Sie schmerzhaft sind oder nicht schmerzhaft.
Ja?
Das sind Angaben, die wichtig sind.
Also Größe, Verschieblichkeit und Schmerzhaft.
Das sind Informationen, die ganz gut sind
bei der Körperknotenversuchung.
Verschieblich, nicht verschiebbar, sondern verschieblich.
Verschieblich.
Okay, Sam und der Sucht,
beides als Lymphknoten verschieblich,
nicht druckdolent, ja?
Nicht druckdolent.
Nicht schmerzhaft, okay.
Er hat auch Yukreis und Blauflecken,
viele verschiedene Körperteile.
Was bedeutet das?
Fachbegriff von Blauflecken, will Herr Kollege hören?
Wie bitte?
Er wollte einen Fachbegriff hören für Blauflecken, glaube ich.
Chematome?
Ja, oder? Was kann man noch sagen?
Ichkimosu.
Ja, genau.
Ja, bitte erzählen Sie weiter.
Und seine Hausart hat Blutabnahme gehabt.
Das steht, Anämie und Trombositopinie.
Und er hat auch Verstopfung.
Lekostose, oder?
Ja, weiß doch, Lekostose.
Lekostose.
Und er hat keine Fieber, keine Strafstörungen
und keine Wass-Lassen-Probleme.
An vorherkrankungen hat er...
Nein, erstmal begleit symptoma.
Alles...
sagen.
Begleit symptoma.
Ja.
Was fehlt noch?
Er hat gesagt, wenn er Drucken hat im Magenbereich,
er hat Druckschmerzen.
Genau, Druckschmerzen, linke Oberbauch hat er gesagt, ja, so direkt.
Bei Hausart, ja. Richtig.
Projetis, haben wir ja gesagt.
Hat sie gesagt, Yukkreis, ja.
Yukkreis, ja.
Und vor Erkrankungen hat er den Bluthoff-Druck seit 20 Jahren...
Seit 20 Jahren.
Mhm.
Und gegen...
gegen Bluthoff, gegen Hypertonie,
Artillerhypertonie, hat, nimmt er, kann das sein,
einmal am Tag,
ein und vor 10 Jahren hat er Schlag-Ampferl gehabt.
Aber zurzeit ohne pathologische Befunde hat er...
Wo ist der Schlag-Ampferl? Was bedeutet auf latinisch?
Apoplex.
Ja, Apoplex, Insult, Apoplex, ja.
Zerebralischämie, wie auch immer.
Und er hat gesagt,
Beninprostate, Prostate, Ergrossung oder...
Genau.
Ergrößung.
Aber müssen wir Beninprostate Hypopilasi sagen, Herr Cahne?
Wäre besser, ja.
Prostate Hypopilasi?
Beninprostate Hypopilasi, ja.
Und man wird mit BPH abgekreuzt, manchmal, in Arztbriefen.
Ja.
Und wegen Prostate, Ergrossung, hat er 2-mal Nacht 2-mal Nekturin.
Mhm.
Vor acht Jahren hat er total in der Protöese femo operiert.
Hüfte oder kurze?
Hüfte.
Aber rechts oder links?
Ich glaube, er hat es rechts gesagt.
Hüfte rechts, weswegen kann sie nach einem traumatischen Hüftkopffraktur sagen?
Nach Hüfte-Anlagebeizustand nach traumatischer Schenkelheistfaktur.
Als Jugend hat er apanikthomie?
Als Jugendlicher.
Zurzeit hat er nicht trafen, aber seit 30 Jahren Einpackung am Tag hat er geraucht.
Trinke er selten Alkohol einmal am Monat.
Er hat keine Drogenkontaktieren.
Er ist ex-Raucher seit 25 bis 30 Jahren und davor ungefähr 30 Packiers.
Er hat verwitwets und dreimal verwendet.
Er ist verwitwets.
Er ist verwitwets und hat drei Kinder.
Sie sind gesund.
Er hat zwei Geschwester.
Er hat zwei Geschwester gegen Brust,
die Mama-Karzinom gestorben.
Er hat zwei Geschwester gegen Apoplex.
Er hat keine bekannte Allergie.
Er hat drei Mal Covid-19 geimpft.
Er hat keine Griechen gegen Griechen.
Er hat keine Influenza-Impfung.
Haben Sie den Patienten gefragt, was er beruflich macht?
Er hat als Chemie-Fahrer bei den Farbwerken in Frankfurt höchst gearbeitet.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Wir machen einmal eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Ich empfehle die Patienten Koloskopie.
Ich möchte die Unterbauchschmerzen.
Ich möchte eine ökologische Diagnose machen.
Woran denken Sie da, in welcher Diagnose?
Magengastro.
Magengastro ist ein sehr seltener
Er hat eine Schwäche, eine Miebedingung.
Welche ist in dem Alter?
Magengastro ist ein sehr seltener Er, ein sehr seltener Er.
Magengastro ist ein sehr seltener Er.
Magengastro ist eine sehr seltener Er.